welcome back to Cameron and Miliband
lies a battle for number 10 the Prime
Minister has been interviewed by Jeremy
Paxman and now it's the turn of our
studio audience to put their questions
to him so without further ado Prime
Minister here we go let's start with
Matthew brand where are you Matthew
there's Matthew let's sir have your
question Matthew Prime Minister what do
you think our Ed Miliband's best
qualities that's a tricky one to start
with but thank you Matthew for the
question I look I think all of us who
put ourselves forward all actually
believe in serving the public in trying
to do the right thing we disagree with
each other sometimes passionately
sometimes as yesterday in the House of
Commons rather noisily but we all
believe in public service in trying to
do the right thing for our country one
thing I admire about Edie is that when
we had to take difficult decisions about
sending British forces in to help with
others to try and defeat ISIL the
murderers death cult in Iraq he stepped
forward and said yes this is the right
thing to do David let's let's do that
together and vote together in the House
of Commons and I'd mad that we did call
him weak and despicable didn't Eve we do
sometimes in the House of Commons use
phrases that perhaps after as we think
patches a bit over the top
I took my well I remember the same day
he called me dodgy and something else so
sometimes I took my children yesterday
and Nancy and Elwyn 9 and 11 and they
said afterwards you know dad if we
behave like that at school you know it
wouldn't be so good so trying to explain
sometimes it gets a bit heated there is
a point to it though which is it's the
time of the week when the Prime
Minister's got to demonstrate that
you're across all the issues and so does
make the government accountable to
Parliament in a way that if you're not
across the issues then things will
change pretty quickly so it does have a
point but we don't always behave as well
as we should okay let's bring in